okay I have to be honest with all of you
right from the start for the past few
months a lot of people have been telling
me that I have to check out oshinoko
that it's one of the best new anime of
2023 that there's a lot of hype around
it and that it includes some really
powerful social commentary that I would
definitely be interested in but when I
talked to my friend Knox Taco about it
and asked him why this anime is so
popular he told me the premise of the
show and I thought it was easily the
cringiest thing I have ever heard
spoilers for season 1 of the anime ahead
by the way but when Knox told me that
this anime is about an adult Doctor Who
is an idol otaku and who dies and is
reincarnated as the baby of his favorite
Idol I nearly hung up the phone on him
right then and there I could not believe
that this was a real story I mean I can
understand being isekai to another world
as a vending machine but this this was
too much I honestly wasn't going to give
this a chance especially since the first
episode was the length of a freaking
movie but then people I know end respect
kept telling me over and over again that
I need to watch this anime at the very
least I need to watch that
feature-length film of a first episode
so I did it I finally did it the first
episode wasn't perfect especially since
Idol culture is not something I'm
normally interested in but here's the
thing I didn't hate it in fact it pretty
much pulled me in and I kept watching I
watched the whole first episode and the
Twist near the end of the episode
absolutely floored me even though
everyone was talking about this I was
not spoiled on Ice death and I'll be
honest I didn't see it coming in an
instant I's tragic death completely
changed the direction of the entire
series and while the twist itself was
compelling and thought-provoking this
was still a really risky move the series
suddenly went from ai's Journey to
becoming a legendary Idol while secretly
raising two twin babies to her dying and
those babies becoming high schoolers
with their own Journeys and Ambitions
the audience might have lost interest
right there because their expectations
for what this series was were subverted
so radically and so suddenly and yet I
kept watching I wanted to see what
happens next I started to actually like
these characters especially aqua and
Kana and while I would never engage in
something as low brow as shipping I
gotta be real team Kana all the way
anyway the people recommending this
anime to me were right there is
definitely a lot of extremely
interesting social commentary in this
series including a whole bunch of
fascinating and terrifying truths about
the entertainment industry in Japan
about Idol culture about parasocial
relationships online harassment
dangerous stalkers the media
manipulating the truth for views and
engagement even when this manipulation
is actively harming someone and so on so
even though I'm not someone who is
usually interested in Idol culture as
someone who is into anime and philosophy
and as someone who does online content
creation for a living I ended up being
drawn into the world of oshinoko and
it's characters in spite of myself a lot
of people have already done a great job
talking about the Dark Side of idol
culture and the Japanese entertainment
industry as portrayed in oshinoko and
even though there are some aspects of
this culture that are specific to Japan
with the Unstoppable rise of the
internet a lot of this stuff has gone
Global we may not have an exact
equivalent to Japanese idol culture in
Western mainstream media but if you've
spent any time on Twitter or other
social media then you know that there
are plenty of fans outside of Japan who
participate in Japanese idol culture or
an adjacent fan cultures like K-pop Stan
culture or YouTuber culture instead of
talking at length about some of these
dark themes that many others have talked
about already from parasocial
relationships and online harassment to
exploitative talent agencies and
deceptive marketing I thought I'd do
something a little bit different in this
video I want to talk about you or I
guess all of us who participate in this
type of culture and everyone who strives
to become an idol despite all the
terrible stuff that clearly takes place
in this industry to me one of the
craziest and most disturbing things
about oshinoko is just how little impact
eyes horrifying death had on wider Idol
culture in that world when it happened
everyone was shocked and saddened but
then the news cycle shifted to something
else and everyone just moved on the idol
industry just kept chugging along
thousands and thousands of girls were
still striving to become Idols knowing
full well what happened to I and most
disturbing of all at least to me is the
fact that I's own daughter Ruby decided
to become an idol I mean think about
that for a second she literally
witnessed some of the darkest aspects on
the industry she saw her own mother
brutally murdered before her very eyes
by a deranged Idol Stan and her takeaway
from all of that was that she too wanted
to become an idol she too wanted to put
herself in that very same dangerous
situation that claimed her mother's life
now yes Ruby's unique circumstances as
someone who was reincarnated and who
lived a very difficult and painfully
isolated past life helped to explain her
desire to become an idol to some extent
but Ruby is not the only one who
desperately wants to become an idol many
other girls who are not reincarnations
and who are fully aware of what happened
to I also decided to become Idols that
said with Ruby having actually witnessed
the murder her desire to follow in her
mother's tragic footsteps just seemed so
disturbing to me Aqua I can totally
understand he realizes how dark and
cruel this industry is and he is trying
to get Justice for his mother while also
secretly trying to protect his sister
but Ruby's perspective and the
perspective of so many other young women
who want to become Idols so badly really
got me thinking why does anyone want to
become an idol why does anyone want to
essentially live a double life
pretending to be something they're not
in public while trying their best to
keep their private lives and true
personalities a secret why does anyone
want to join these exploitative talent
agencies that pay only a fraction of the
talent's earnings to the actual talent
meaning that most aspiring Idols
essentially live in poverty and only the
most successful ones actually make a
decent living the series even
establishes that the vast majority of
these girls who are striving to become
Idols are high schoolers and even 20 is
considered old in this industry so why
would any high schooler who is already
busy with school and just trying to live
a normal life spend hours upon hours
every single day learning how to sing
and dance and act instead of actually
having a childhood why does anyone want
to risk becoming a target of online
harassment and possibly even the target
of a deranged violent stalker just for
the possibility of becoming a successful
Idol I mean it's not like being an idol
is a good long-term career career plan
even the most popular Idols will get
older and once they're considered too
old to be Idols most of them will be
shunned and forgotten by the industry
sure a few of them might transition into
other careers like acting or modeling
but most of them won't and after your
agency has taken their cut you may not
even be left with that much Financial
Security despite having once been an
extremely popular Entertainer so why why
work so hard to become an idol I think
that it comes down to a very basic human
desire for gaining the approval and
admiration of other people and even
though I am nowhere close to being an
idol as a content creator whose job it
is to inform and entertain complete
strangers on the internet I think that I
have a unique perspective on this
subject as I will argue in the remainder
of this video that desire for approval
and admiration from others is not a good
thing in fact it can be an extremely
harmful and dangerous thing I know this
might seem hypocritical from someone
whose job depends on complete strangers
on the internet enjoying their videos
but some of History's Greatest
philosophers and philosophies have
argued that this very thing this desire
for approval and praise from others is
the cause of most of the problems facing
modern society today and it's only
getting worse I's tragic death is just
the beginning most people don't know
this but before becoming a YouTuber I
spent many years studying political
philosophy and I even earned a PhD in
political philosophy I was planning to
become like a professor or something but
then I couldn't find a job despite all
those degrees and years of schooling so
I started making anime YouTube videos
with my brother I guess in that sense I
can kind of relate to Kana because
despite having some initial success in
my original career I was eventually
rejected by the industry and had to
switch gears pretty drastically that
said all that study of philosophy does
come in handy when analyzing anime and
manga and this video is a perfect
example of that one of my favorite
philosophers Jean-Jacques Rousseau
talked about two distinct forms of
self-love amul and
is a primitive form of self-love
possessed by all animals including
humans this love predates Society itself
and it exists even among people who
never interact with other people it
refers to just a basic desire for
self-preservation and it doesn't depend
on the opinion of others a wild rabbit
loves itself in the sense that it wants
to preserve itself so if it sees a human
running up to it menacingly it will run
away but if some human yells an insult
at the rabbit from far away the rabbit
won't be bothered in the least as long
as its basic needs are met a rabbit
doesn't care about what some human or
any other animal thinks of it a rabbit
has no desire to be loved and praised by
other animals and the lack of such love
and praise will not affect its mood
Rousseau believes that a long time ago
humans lived this way too kind of like
self-sufficient cavemen who survived on
their own and only interacted with other
people once in a while but then
eventually humans started living
together the first societies were formed
and the Primitive AMU the SWA was
replaced by another form of self-love
amuapropra unlike Amour the SWA which
comes only from within oneself amul
propra is a form of self-love that can
only be achieved by gaining the approval
of others amul propra is essentially the
root cause of all of modern society's
problems it leads us to compare
ourselves to others to try to stand out
and be better than others and to desire
to be loved and praised by others this
is the beginning of egotistical
competition inequality and Corruption as
well as all of our vices such as Pride
Envy greed and so on Rousseau's ultimate
conclusion is that we must turn this
amul popra away from Petty vanity and
towards more positive things like love
of virtue morality body and good laws
and institutions but in reality one can
argue that since Rousseau's death some
250 years ago a Mulk propra has only
gotten more extreme and destructive
within our society we are not directing
our amul proper towards virtue and good
institutions but instead we are becoming
more vain egotistical and focused on
shallow Pursuits like fame money and
physical pleasures and because we are so
shallow and reliant on the opinions of
others our need to be loved and praised
by others has never been greater than it
is now in the age of social media I mean
just look at how cloud has become a
powerful currency in this day and age
and look at how fake and exaggerated
most people's Instagram and other social
media profiles are I guess to some
extent all of us are cosplaying as Idols
all of us are posting only the best
parts of our Lives to social media in
the hopes of getting praise from others
and some are even using Photoshop to
make themselves look better or renting
fans cars and houses and claiming that
they owned them and again it's all for
that sweet sweet clout some can even
live off Cloud if they can leverage it
into sponsorship and brand deals I mean
just look at the Kardashians to bring
this back to oshinoko one line from Kana
arima really struck me she was a child
star who fell out of favor with the
industry as she got older and she kind
of made adjustments and lowered her
expectations but her desire to be adored
never went away in the final episode of
season 1 we learned that for over 10
years she has been crying out someone
please look at me say that you need me
but why why does Kana an intelligent
talented and beautiful young woman need
others to look at her why does she need
other people to need her and praise her
and worship her as an idol it's funny
but all of the world's major
philosophies and religions teach you
that this is the exact recipe for
unhappiness whether you you ask Rousseau
or the stoics or Christian theologians
or Zen Buddhists they will all tell you
that you shouldn't be too attached to
the physical world and you most
certainly shouldn't be attached to what
others think of you at the end of the
day you can't actually control what
others think of you as hard as you might
try as we saw with akane the truth can
even be manipulated to make you look bad
and you can become a social outcast
through little or no fault of your own
so allowing your happiness to depend on
what others think of you is the perfect
recipe for constant unhappiness becoming
an idol is certain to make you unhappy
whenever public opinion turns against
you for whatever reason or when you get
older and the industry rejects you it's
interesting when you think about it but
as fans of the show we are of course
rooting for our favorite characters to
succeed in their quest to become idols
but in reality if we really care about
those characters we should probably be
rooting against them at least when it
comes to them becoming Idols because
that is most likely going to make them
very unhappy in the end in fact being an
idol fan is also going to make you
unhappy if you take these public
personas and assume that you know who
they really are behind the scenes once
you inevitably learn that you don't know
them and that the real person behind the
Persona doesn't meet the expectations of
your perfect Idol fantasy you will
inevitably be disappointed and some who
are unhinged might even react the way
that eyes stalker did the truth is that
we have a vicious cycle here aspiring
Idols are so desperate to be loved and
praised that they are willing to live a
lie just like I hoshino did they are
willing to be exploited by a ruthless
industry and give up their childhood and
their privacy in order to please
obsessive fans their dream is to become
Idols but even if they achieve their
dream they are very unlikely to act
actually be happy in terms of the fans
many of them are obsessing over a
fictional Persona over an idle fantasy
that will never live up to the real
person behind the camera and it really
does take two to tango if fans would
stop being parasocial and unrealistic
the idols wouldn't have to live a lie
but at the same time if the aspiring
Idols didn't have this need for praise
and approval from complete strangers the
worst elements of the fan base would
have no one to obsess over we as humans
desire approval and praise from others
even if they are complete strangers and
we also like to look up to and
borderline worship celebrities maybe
it's just human nature maybe it's the
corruption of modern society but it's
definitely not our fault I'm sure that
most of us here especially those of us
with limited exposure to Japan's Idol
culture would like to think of ourselves
as the good kind of fan we wouldn't stop
supporting someone just because they
have a significant other or a family
right we know that these are real people
with real lives not our own personal
fantasies we know that the celebrities
we like and the content creators we
support probably have completely
different opinions than we do on some
social and political issues that are
important to us I mean there's no way
that everyone whose content we enjoy
agrees with us on everything right
that's obvious we definitely wouldn't
try to cancel someone on Twitter for
saying something years ago that we now
find offensive or for supporting a
political position that is different
from our own that would be crazy right
we're not like those obsessive Idol
culture fans in Japan we wouldn't tell
the content creators we support what
games they can or cannot play what jokes
they can or cannot say what accounts
they can or cannot interact with that
would be ridiculous Idol culture can be
dark sure but that's not our fault we
are not the villains of this story
right